ausgerechnet brüssel und straßburg von
wo aus unser leben zu großen teilen
reguliert wird dort ausgerechnet dort
wird offenbar geklaut getrickst und
gemobbt besonders häufig sind handys
laptops und computer tablets
verschwunden es kommt auch zu sexuellen
belästigungen und mobbing das geht aus
einem internen bericht für den
haushaltskontrollausschuss hervor der
bild vorliegt und zwar in person
unsere politik chef jan schäfer jan was
ist da los also es gibt wie in jeder
behörde auch im europäischen parlament
gewisse dinge die nicht rechtens sind
beispielsweise diebstahl und interessant
ist zu sehen dass im jahr 2020 das sind
zahlen die sich auf das vergangene jahr
beziehen die zahl der diebstähle mit 199
fällen nahezu doppelt so hoch war wie im
jahr 2009 10 das heißt also dass gerade
in der korona pandemie viele büros
natürlich verweist waren und da der eine
oder andere langfinger deutlich stärker
zugegriffen hat was es gerade schon
erwähnt tablets smartphones das sind so
die dinge computer die am häufigsten
gestohlen wurden es gibt aber nicht nur
diebstahl sondern es gibt auch noch
betrug betrugsfällen 18 sind es gewesen
im jahr
2020 betrug das ist beispielsweise das
falsch abrechnen von
mitarbeiter- pauschalen oder auch von
reisekosten bei denen dann auch geld in
die eigene tasche geflossen ist da gab
es insgesamt ein schaden von rund 1,3
millionen euro im vergangenen jahr und
dann ist das thema mobbing natürlich
noch eins was wichtiges da gab es 2020
insgesamt 17 fällen da gibt es dann oft
um sexuelle belästigung am arbeitsplatz
in zwölf fällen waren abgeordnetem
involviert in fünf fällen war das also
beziehung bei mitarbeitern oder unter
einander von mitarbeiter wie viele
menschen arbeiten fürs eu-parlament
also sind knapp 8000 rund 7.800
mitarbeiter gibt es auch insgesamt
seinen ins thema das sowohl eine sehr
sehr große behörde wir haben etwas über
700 abgeordnete aus allen 27 eu-staaten
und dann insgesamt natürlich jeder
abgeordnete ja noch mitarbeiter hat
kommt man auf rund 7800 personen
interessant ist dabei dass es nicht nur
im eu parlament im vergangenen corona ja
deutlich mehr diebstähle beispielsweise
gegeben hat sondern auch aus dem
bundestag wissen wir dass dort ist ja
die präsenzpflicht auch zum teil
aufgehoben gewesen man hat in vielen
fällen ja in kleineren rahmen getagt
vieles wurde digitalisiert und im
vergangenen sommer im juni hat die
bundestagspolizei und alle abgeordneten
auch eine warnung heraus geschickt und
hat gesagt es tags polizia achtung
achtung schließt eure handys tablet und
so weiter viel viel besser ein es gibt
ja auch langfinger die durch den
bundestag gehen und es ist in der in den
wochen zuvor zu deutlich mehr einbrüchen
auch im bundestagsbüro es gekommen als
vorher also hat auch damit zu tun dass
die natürlich nicht zu stark besetzt
waren also man jeden aber eher gedacht
rückläufig ist ehrlich gesagt weil alle
im home office sind man nimmt ja auch
seinen sein tablet seinen rechner sein
handy mit dass die zahlen eigentlich
nicht so explodieren aber es gibt
natürlich eine grundausstattung in den
büros es gibt auch geldkassetten
abgeordnete hatten zum teil ein bisschen
bargeld auch vor beispielsweise man
nimmt ja auch nicht die ganze it
ausstattung eines büros damit das sind
jetzt im tal büros mit 34 mitarbeitern
auch also da ist dann einiges in den
büros und wer zeit hat weil er weiß das
büro ist ja heute gar nicht besetzt und
besucht der kann natürlich da ordentlich
verlaufen mit einem monitor einfach mal
schön es ist auch aus den technischen
kaffee und tee entwendet worden wie die
bundestagsverwaltung dann auf bild
anfrage auch mitgeteilt hat also nicht
nur in den büros sondern auch im
täglichen lob an die langfinger
zugeschlagen frage es natürlich richten
sich die ermittlungen jetzt gegen die
abgeordneten selbst oder gegen personal
mitarbeiter reinigungskräfte
sicherheitskräfte wer immer das kommt
natürlich darauf an je nachdem wie die
verdachtsfälle sind also beispielsweise
beim thema betrug wenn wir da falsche
reisekostenabrechnungen zum beispiel
haben dann ist am ende natürlich wenn
der abgeordnete dinge unterschrieben hat
der abgeordnete dran und muss dann klar
stellen warum so etwas falsch gelaufen
ist oder was da genau passiert ist dann
haftet der natürlich der unterschrieben
hat im regelfall ist dass der
abgeordnete bei diebstählen da wird es
dann natürlich ganz normal ermittlungen
geben muss man schauen also wer war zu
dem zeitpunkt im haus war nicht im haus
waren das vielleicht auch externe
personen die da durch die büros gegangen
sind wird man alles aufklären müssen
dass er natürlich dann sache der
staatsanwaltschaft